reese record pour les douaniers français
droit 158000 cachets d'ecstasy de drogue
qui séduit de plus en plus de
consommateurs qui ne se méfie pas de ses
conséquences sur la santé corse deux
mois et demi après l'assassinât du
préfet claude erignac c'est le grand
chambardement dans l'île remplacement
aujourd'hui d'un préfet et du patron de
la police judiciaire
les producteurs de chou-fleur bouton
vous rencontrer leur ministre monsieur
louis le pensec créé vendredi prochain
la filière du chou fleur du producteur
au consommateur c'est notre enquête de
ce soir dans la nuit du 15 avril 1912
sombrait le titanic
après le succès phénoménal du film et
cérémonies anniversaires ont pris cette
année une toute autre ampleur
pour les amateurs du genre le
spécialiste du film fantastique john
carpenter présente cette semaine les
vampires
madame monsieur bonsoir les services des
douanes installé à l'entrée dû tunnel
sous la manche près de calais ont
annoncé aujourd'hui une prise record de
exactement 2 357 1900 km ecstasy
découvert le 25 mars dernier à
l'occasion d'une fouille impromptue à
bord d'un camion à destination de
l'angleterre appartenant à une
entreprise de transport belge
cette prise représente un record dans la
mesure où elle est en quantité à peu
près le double de tout ce qui a été
saisi en france durant l'année 1990
tirer curtet bernard dussaut 358 mille
cachets d'ecstasy destinées au marché
britannique
c'est une prise record effectué il y à
un mois au terminal ferroviaire du
tunnel sous la manche près de calais le
camion venait de belgique l'ex d'asie
sans doute les pays bas c'est en
fouillant la remorque qui n'était pas
tout à fait en règle que les douaniers
ont fait la découverte
j'ai cheka retrait quand même
l'hypothèse d'amateur il faut bien voir
que l'ecstasy plus à cocaïne ça ça
représente quand même plus d'un milliard
de centimes
bon je pense que n'importe qui n'a pas
une telle somme à mettre sur la table
les policiers n'ont pas encore
totalement achevé leur enquête
il essaye de remonter jusqu'au
laboratoire une installation comme
celle-ci démantelés en france
en 91 sur ces images tournées par les
services de police
les ingénieurs chimistes le mans vers
explique ici la fabrication des
molécules d'ecstasy ou policiers cette
drogue
apparu au milieu des années 80 pose en
effet un problème aux législateurs
c'est une drogue dite mutante c'est à
dire que les chimistes clandestins en
modifie la composition au fur et à
mesure d interdiction
la loi doit donc s'adapter mais
aujourd'hui ce qui inquiète le plus des
services de lutte contre les stupéfiants
c'est la quantité saisie à calais c'est
plus que tous les services de douanes
gendarmerie et police réunis pour toute
l'année
87 c'est relativement inquiétant ça veut
dire qu'il y à une disponibilité très
grande du produit donc qu'il y a des
laboratoire qui le fabrique
c'est inquiétant également pour la
grande bretagne parce que ça signifie
qu'il ya là un marché de consommation
potentiels importants et inquiétants
également pour les autres pays dont la
france l'espagne l'italie en france du
laboratoire seulement ont été démantelés
la drogue semblent venir d'ailleurs les
policiers ont coutume de dire qu'il n'a
intercepte que 5 à 10% du trafic
l'ecstasy se présente sous forme vous
l'avez vu de cachet qui donne un
sentiment paraît-il de fort hills est un
produit
toutes proportions gardées peu cher à
l'achat qu'un destin et dont la vente se
développe à grande échelle
chez les plus jeunes notamment l'ecstasy
que certains appellent la pilule du
bonheur est en fait à terme très
rapidement celle du malheur dans la
mesure où les spécialistes sont formels
elle laisse de graves séquelles
françoise allait michel levasseur le
produit de base la méthylène dioxine
amphétamines combiné à d'autres
molécules
ce sont des amphétamines très
particulière classe est interdite sur le
plan international parce que trip hop
sic
le comprimé s'achète 100 à 150 francs
elle se consomme dans les soirées
l'ecstasy ne rend pas agressif mais
contrairement aux idées reçues et
dangereuse dans une soirée vous pouvez
vous risquez d'avoir une fièvre très
élevé vous risquez de faire un collapsus
vous risquez des troubles de la
coagulation et troubles cardiaques une
mort subite ça arrive sorti de là des
convulsions également en avons vu à la
sortie vous risque un accident de
voiture si vous en prenez un petit peu à
moyen terme plusieurs fois dans quelques
mois vous pouvez parcourir au recours de
vieillissement cérébral qui suit en
quelques généralement en quelques
dizaines d'années la destruction des
cellules nerveuses éprouvés
scientifiquement chez le singe et leur a
faussement présenté comme une drogue qui
ne provoque pas de dépendance l'ecstasy
peut conduire à terme à des troubles
psychiatriques graves la loi
républicaine doit s'appliquer en corse
comme sur le continent
c'est par cette formule somme toute
laconique que le ministre de l'intérieur
jean pierre chevènement a commenté
aujourd'hui le chambardement qui s'opère
au plus haut niveau dans
l'administration la justice et la police
avec aujourd'hui le remplacement du
patron de la pj de corse et du préfet de
haute corse des mutations qui
interviennent après d'autres de céder
semaine dernière et deux mois et demi
après l'assassinât du préfet claude
erignac reportage jacques cardoze jean
françois forget c'est une véritable
nouvelle équipe qui prend place
aujourd'hui dans l'île de beauté
derrière bernard bonnet installé il ya
deux mois
voici le nouveau préfet de haute corse
bernard lemaire il devra lui veiller à
l'application des décisions de justice
il va falloir faire en sorte que sur les
dossiers critiques nous rétablissions la
rigueur nous rétablissions la loi mais
qu'en même temps nous fassions north en
sorte que les dossiers les plus
importants des bouches et débouchent
rapidement demetrius dragacci fait les
frais des nouvelles nominations le
patron de la police judiciaire est
remplacé par frédéric veaux commissaire
divisionnaire venue de marseille
trois policiers des renseignements
généraux quittent leurs fonctions
un poste est créé avec un juge
d'instruction spécialisé dans les
enquêtes financières des nominations à
tous les échelons police justice et
administratifs tous les moyens sont donc
donnés à l'application du contrôle de
légalité
ce qui est vrai c'est que tous les
dossiers sont ouverts 1 et
qu'effectivement il y a dans l'exercice
du contrôle de légalité une certaine
automaticité
ceux ci concernent notamment le
contentieux de l'urbanisme
nous avons à peu près une quarantaine de
décision de justice qui pour des raisons
d'ailleurs très différents tous très
diverses ne sont pas encore appliquées
l'un de ces dossiers visent la cadec où
une perquisition a été menée ce matin
cet organisme parapublic est soupçonné
d'avoir prêté trop facilement il fait
donc l'objet à son tour d'une enquête
financière de nombreux documents ont été
saisis dans le secteur de l'hôtellerie
et du tourisme où plus de 300 millions
de francs d'emprunt ne sont pas
recouvrir le ministre de l'agriculture
louis le pensec vient d'annoncer qu'il
recevrait vendredi matin les
représentants des agriculteurs bretons
qui sont d'accord pour cette rencontre
après une semaine environ de
tergiversations rendez vous est donc
finalement pris ce qui va peut-être
décider des producteurs de chou fleur
qui occupe le pont de morlaix depuis
plus de 24 heures maintenant à lever les
barrages mathieu chef jean-pierre
pasteur au loin la relève
14h c'est le passage de témoin à tour de
rôle une vingtaine d'agriculteurs se
succèdent pour assurer la garde du pont
de morlaix l'occasion de faire le point
on prend la relève de deux heures du
matin jusqu'à 8 heures
donc c'est toujours le même
renouvellement dans les cantons le pont
est toujours bloquée on retiendra le
temps niveau dans l'après midi une
délégation d'élus des petites communes
des environs et un sénateur savantes sur
le tapis de chou-fleur réduit en
bouillie par la pluie ils sont venus
apporter leur soutien
pour ma part je considère qu'ils ont
quelques petites or la semaine dernière
mais que cette semaine ils ont
parfaitement raison c'est donc les gens
qu'on est avec eux de toute façon sans
citer des personnes il ya eu déjà des
contacts avec le ministre directement il
des finistériens lui aussi on le connaît
nous sommes tous deux au conseil général
l'huile est aussi mais ne sont prêts à
aller le voir immédiatement s'il faut
mais taux de suites c'est évident mais
il ya certainement des méthodes et
surtout de mettre de côté de l'orgueil
la fierté parce que moi d'un coach
ministre dit il ya des petits paysans
etc
c'est pas vrai il est plus que temps que
toujours nous évite
vite vite visiblement le dialogue de
sourds entre le ministre de
l'agriculture louis le pensec et les
agriculteurs touche à sa fin il aurait
réussi à ajuster leurs emplois du temps
les légumiers sont attendus vendredi à
10 heures au ministère on parlera argent
jusque là le barrage devrait rester en
place
il ya un problème de fond pour les
producteurs de légumes breton et de chou
fleur en particulier la concurrence
d'autres pays aux coûts salariaux moins
élevés comme l'espagne il est également
un problème d'évolution des goûts
alimentaires des français beaucoup moins
friands de chou fleur qu'il ya quelques
années encore et puis il ya le problème
conjoncturel de la chute des cours
comment s'explique la multiplication par
6 ou par 8 en moyenne entre le prix payé
au producteur et le prix d'achat au
détail enquête
arnaud boutet jacques devaux entre la
récolte du chou fleur dans les chants
bretons et sa vente sur un marché
parisien
son prix a été multiplié par 8 1 francs
40 par chou fleur c'est le prix de
retrait moyens que touchent les
producteurs depuis plusieurs mois à cela
s'ajoute l'emballage un franc 20 plus la
tva
le chou-fleur arrive chez l'expéditeur à
3 francs 25 puis de base aura été fixé
ici dans ce qu'on appelle le marché aux
cadres il en existe 3 en bretagne qui
fonctionne tous les jours de la semaine
le cadran analyse tout simplement
l'offre et la demande dans la plus
grande transparence
c'est le seul qui permette une
efficacité dans la gestion d'un prix
autrement ça devient opaque
lorsque le chou-fleur prend la route
vers les marchés internationaux
l'expéditeur a déjà prélevé sa marge
5 % plus le coût du transport au petit
matin les légumes arrivent à rungis pour
approvisionner la capitale
souffleur qui portent là
qu'ils perdent près de versailles
le prix a été fixé la veille entre
l'expéditeur et les grossistes de rungis
22 francs le colis de 6 cela fait 3
francs 50 la pièce d'un cent quarante au
chauffeur x this as fait ça fait 8
francs à 846 genre arrivent à vendre de
francs à rungis bon c'est jésus il ya
quand même une quinzaine de francs 15 16
francs qui se baladent et qui représente
quand même eu beaucoup plus le produit
ou le vendre aujourd'hui à aujourd'hui
l'argentine qui veut aujourd'hui on va
le vendre en masse et le vent demain de
7 francs les six pièces soit 4,50 la
pièce 450 c'est donc le nouveau prix
s'engage alors une nouvelle négociation
avec les détaillants qui viennent
acheter un jeu de guitare
c'est pareil ça paraissait les axes
d'avenir
tel effet lui connaît
sur pc
27 francs le colis le prix ne bougera
pas aujourd'hui le couple en eau plus
cher que la semaine dernière
et on le jette allez c'est gai c'est au
jour sur les marchés parisiens le
chou-fleur se vend alors 8 à 10 francs
la pièce mais les clients se font de
plus en plus rares voilà une dizaine
d'années on l'an passé 300
avant c'était pareil à 8,9 rang il reste
bon marché mais ne se vend pas car en
fait
le malaise est ailleurs les français
n'aiment plus ce pauvre chou fleur
le mauvais temps sur la france continue
de sévir les températures sont
heureusement à la hausse la pluie a
remplacé le froid la neige et le gel qui
est le danger le plus redouté par les
agriculteurs en cette saison notamment
les producteurs de fruits et les
viticulteurs grâce à des moyens de
chauffage installer la nuit au pied des
vignes on ne déplore aucun dégât majeur
même si certains n'ont pu éviter qu'une
partie de leur récolte ne soit
endommagée comme c'est le cas dans le
département de l'aude dans le fameux
vignoble de la blanquette de limoux
reportage muriel de la saga gilles
berrut sens j'ai 54 ans de vie niro
depuis l'âge de 14 ans ariary c'est la
première fois de ma vie que je vois une
chose pareille dans cette haute vallée
de l'aude
la température est descendue jusqu'à -5
degrés les bourgeons prometteurs ont été
grillés par le gel ici aucune parcelle
ne donnera deux raisons cette année les
bourgeons qui ont été brûlées par le gel
von ont péri
et ce sera le compte de ce que nous
appelons le compte à rebours jambes qui
va arriver à redémarrer mais qui ne
portera pas de fuir les quarante et une
communes de l'appellation ont toutes été
touchés par le gel environ 20% de la
production lundi soir les vignerons sont
restés impuissants face à la chute du
thermomètre
ici pas de système de chauffage ou
d'aspersion d'eau dans les vignes trop
cher ses méthodes sont laissés aux
grandes appellations dans l'aude comme
ailleurs les vignerons ne sont jamais
assuré contre le gel aussi beaucoup
espèrent être déclarées sinistrées pour
obtenir des aides de l'état
un sondage ifop pour l'événement du
jeudi indique pour la première fois ce
que les parisiens pensent de la bataille
de la mairie de paris
46% sont plutôt favorables un maire de
gauche en cas de vote contre 41% un
maire de droite à droite il choisirait
en priorité edouard balladur devant
jacques toubon et assez loin derrière
jean tiberi l'actuel maire à gauche
dominique strauss kahn devant daniel
vaillant et georges sarre pour l'heure
on en est encore au duel entre la
majorité dans la majorité rpr udf qui se
déchire avec le maire jean tibéri qui
n'écarte pas un geste d'apaisement
toutefois à l'égard de jacques toubon
qui a mis sa gestion en cause j'ai vite
imbert patrick fois naturellement
j'ajoute que les problèmes de sécurité
aux en fichait complètement
c'est ce que j'ai cru comprendre et
c'est vrai qu'elles sont un peu passés
au second plan les propositions de
jacques toubon pour améliorer la
sécurité de l'est parisien
car ce que l'on était aujourd'hui
c'était plutôt sa réponse à la dernière
offre en date de jean tiberi que tous
les élus de droite se retrouvent autour
d'une table pour discuter a suggéré le
maire de paris
apparemment jacques toubon ne veut pas
on ne peut pas disputer entre ceux qui
sont considérés en quelque sorte comme
des exclus et les parias et sous des
pestiférés chef audet j'ajoute
putschistes et ceux qui au contraire
détiendrait le pouvoir la vérité est la
légitimité
les questions de forme et de
susceptibilité sont apparemment
essentiel en cette affaire ce que les
amis de jacques toubon récolte
aujourd'hui c'est que jean tiberi
accorde une audience en bonne et due
forme à leur chef de file et qu'ils
arrêtent leur mauvaise manière pour eux
la nomination de claude annick tissot en
es tu venu pour avoir dénoncé la gestion
de michel giraud à la tête de l'île de
france
elle devient l'une des pièces maîtresses
de l'hôtel de ville aux côtés de jean
tiberi l'un des partisans de jacques
toubon et du coup écarté indignation
si monsieur tiberi pense que ça c'est
une manière du galop et moi je considère
que c'est pas du tout une manière de
dialoguer c'est une manière même de nous
prendre un peu pour des imbéciles
le temps de la conciliation semble
encore loin la ville de paris pourtant
doit continuer de fonctionner jean
tiberi présentera bientôt des textes
devant le conseil municipal seront
qu'ils n'ont voté ce sera l'heure de
vérité nouveaux développements au
conseil régional rhône alpes le
président charles millon a enregistré la
défection de 17 élus rpr udf la
situation devient donc de plus en plus
compliqué pour lui
charles millon doit normalement faire
adopter son budget cette semaine au
conseil des ministres de ce matin la
ministre de l'emploi martine aubry a
présenté le plan français pour l'emploi
destiné à être examiné au sommet
européen de cardiff en grande bretagne
un plan qui reprend les principaux axes
de la politique du gouvernement autour
des 35 heures par semaine et des emplois
pour les jeunes
parallèlement à propos de l'europe le
communiste robert hue dans un entretien
au nouvel observateur réclame une
nouvelle fois un référendum sur la
monnaie sur l'euro la bourse de paris
connaît depuis le début de cette année
une véritable envolée avec ce phénomène
nouveau aujourd'hui des entrepreneurs ne
vont plus chercher l'argent auprès des
banques sur le mans auprès des banques
mais aussi des actionnaires y compris
les petites et moyennes entreprises
exemple sept apprentis coiffeurs
alsaciens qui en six ans à peine est
devenu pdg d'une société de coiffure à
domicile qui emploie 16 cents coiffeuse
sa société vient d'être introduite sur
le second marché à 101 francs l'action
la demande a été 11 fois supérieure à
l'offre reportage kristin booth sylvain
gauthier depuis 1992 christelle patricia
evelyne et beaucoup d'autres sillonnent
les campagnes françaises et pratique
shampoing coupe et permanente à domicile
un nouveau type de services de proximité
imaginé il ya 20 ans par un apprenti
coiffeur dont la seule ambition était de
créer son propre emploi
aujourd'hui il règne sur une société de
1600 coiffeuse à domicile dans toute la
france moi je n'ai rien inventé la
coiffure domicile se faisait depuis le
moyen âge
donc j'ai pas dû faire preuve d'une
grande imagination pour savoir que la
coiffure de missiles répondait à un réel
besoin d'à part du consommateur
seulement je suis cru est tellement cru
qu'aujourd'hui basque dévlopman tu
réalises 77 millions de chiffre
d'affaires et dégagent 10 millions de
francs de bénéfices
une véritable success story qui est né
ici au pied des vosges le secret de la
réussite un statut de salarié pour ces
coiffeuse à domicile payer aux
pourcentages avantages une meilleure
conciliation de la vie familiale et
professionnelle
c'est que je peux m'organiser comme je
veux je suis entièrement indépendante
je choisis mes horaires je choisis mes
clients je j'ai vraiment de l'irb le
libre arbitre
ce qui concerne ce métier là une fois
par mois
mariette fait appel aux services
d'eveline histoire de rafraîchir sa
coupe et d'échanger quelques confidences
c'est pratique c'est très pratique
surtout quand vous êtes âgés ou êtes
malade ou même des personnes qui ont des
enfants qui peuvent qui n'ont pas le
temps les prestations sont les mêmes que
dans un salon les tarifs sont inférieurs
de 15% disent comprise rien n'arrête le
groupe philippe bosc introduit
aujourd'hui en bourse avec l'objectif
d'accroître notre notoriété de façon
nous permettre d'embaucher davantage de
coiffeuse pour répondre à cette demande
incessante de notre clientèle une
introduction au second marché qui va lui
permettre de financer une campagne de
pub une caravane dans le tour de france
avant d'aller prospecter le marché
américain
le la ministre de la justice elisabeth
guigou a présenté aujourd'hui le premier
point de sa réforme de la justice très
attendu le conseil supérieur de la
magistrature chargés d'assister le chef
de l'état dans sa tâche de garant de
l'indépendance de la magistrature va
passer de 12 à 21 membres les magistrats
n'y seront plus majoritaires afin
d'éviter toute tentation de corporatisme
dans le même temps la vie de ce conseil
deviendra indispensable pour la
nomination des hauts magistrats tels que
procureurs et procureurs généraux
l'assurance automobile en france est
obligatoire mais dans le même temps un
assureur pour qu'ils vous représentez
trop de risques peut-être peut bien
refuser de vous assurer pour les très
mauvais conducteur ou pour ceux qui sont
victimes de la malchance à répétition un
courtier une idée d'inventer une société
sos malus il prend votre dossier et se
charge de le plaider auprès les
assureurs benoît nous c'est
jean-françois cheveux dans la famille
des fous du volant il ya parfois de
dangereuses multirécidiviste des
conducteurs qui font des dégâts pas
forcément graze mais que les assureurs
ne pardonnent plus parce qu'ils sont
trop coûteux 3% des actions aujourd'hui
sont ainsi tombés en disgrâce
pour ces parias parfaitement solvable
voici une solution à leur problème des
courtiers d'assurances comme sos malus
ou tous les punis sont ici écouter et
conseiller vous mr jouera ce soir hier
on veut pas vous prendre mais alors
pascal et rue serviez trop détruit la
clé un sos manuce s'engage à péter la
pousse de ces conducteurs auprès des
compagnies d'assurance comme un avocat
dès faudrait son fils
nous sommes là pour aider les clients
non seulement pour trouver une couvée
d'assurance qui les acceptent au
meilleur rapport qualité prix
mais après pour les aider en cas de
sinistre parce qu'il ya forcément des
sinistres après la souscription d'un
contrat d'assurance et nous sommes là
pour faire payer les compagnies pour
assister nos clients autre saint bernard
le bct le bureau central de tarification
un organisme public chargé de faire
appliquer la loi carle assurance est
obligatoire pour une voiture
le bureau examine le dossier de la
personne en question et prononce une
tarification qui va s'imposer à
l'assureur
le bct va donc imposé à l'assureur
choisi de garantir cette personne
pendant un an
l'an dernier ce bureau a traitées 2700
dossier un chiffre en constante
progression depuis trois ans j'ai l'air
de sauter du coq à l'âne mais pas du
tout vous allez le voir en chine les
assureurs n'en sont pas encore au bonus
malus la voiture particulière est encore
réservé là bas disons aux classes les
plus aisées
la circulation y est encore anarchique
et y passer son permis de conduire
relève d'une aventure indiana jones ce
reportage isabelle mischler tristan le
bras
les policiers pékinois ont beau faire
des moulinets très appliquée la rue
reste le lieu de tous les dangers
pas de règle qui tiennent ou plutôt si
la loi du plus fort comme constante
derrière l'anarchie à paroles comment
voulez vous apprendre à conduire dans ce
capharnaüm mademoiselle lui comme les
autres candidats au permis de conduire
et donc prudemment isolés sur un circuit
le véhicule sur lequel on la forme n'a
rien à voir non plus avec la vraie vie
oui bien sûr au début j'aurais peur
quand je conduirai dans la circulation
mais la conduite c'est une question de
pratique
petit à petit ça ira mieux je trouve que
par les temps qui courent avec le
chômage et la compétition c'est un atout
d'avoir son permis et un avantage sur
les autres
il faut en moyenne deux mois de temps et
6 mois de salaire moyen pour acquérir
cette formation particulièrement sur
année dans l'auto école d'état plus de
dix mille élèves parents et une majorité
de jeunes femmes apprennent ici une
théorie qui ne mettront jamais en
pratique la priorité aux piétons sur les
clous par exemple n'existe pas en
réalité
vous comprenez nous sommes un pays en
voie de développement
ce serait bien trop dangereux pour nos
élèves d'être lâché directement dans la
circulation
ce serait dangereux pour les piétons et
pour les autres automobilistes
c'est déjà bien assez encombré les
futurs conducteurs n'ont plus qu'à se
jeter dans la mêlée mais les qui
s'aggrave visiblement au rythme des
progrès de l'industrie automobile et de
l'enrichissement des classes moyennes
dans la seule capitale le parc
automobile a augmenté de près de 40% en
trois ans
personne ne sait plus où donner de la
tête quant aux agents de la circulation
on aurait le tournis à moins après les
accords de paix en irlande du nord les
autorités de dublin ont libéré neuf
membres de l'armée républicaine
irlandaise en signe d'ouverture ce qui a
était en fait très mal pris par les
protestants de belfast mais qui pourrait
être très bien interprété par les
catholiques du sinn fein aile politique
de l'ira qui n'a pas encore donné son
accord à ce traité signé dimanche
dernier un scandale éclabousse les plus
hautes autorités et les plus hauts
responsables des carabiniers italiens
l'équivalent de notre gendarmerie
nationale trois généraux dont le
commandant en chef accusé soit de
corruption soit de collusion avec
certains membres de l'extrême droite
dans un passé récent alain de chalvron
rome le général delfino un des chefs des
carabiniers la gendarmerie italienne
portait beau c'était une vedette il
n'aimait rien tant que témoigner lors
des grands procès mafieux
keith attribuer la gloire d'avoir mis
sous les verrous toto riina le parrain
des parrains de cosa nostra
et bien voilà qu'il pourrait à son tour
se trouvait sur le banc des accusés pour
une histoire pas jolie jolie a tout
plein en juin 97 un riche industriel
italien giuseppe se fiant thing est
enlevé par des bandits sarde désemparé
ses enfants brasse toutes leurs
relations pour tenter d'obtenir la
libération de leur père le général
delfino est un ami de la famille
contacté il accepte de servir
d'intermédiaire avec les ravisseurs
c'est contre la loi mais c'est au nom de
l'amitié une amitié pas tout à fait
désintéressée les juges ont en effet
découvert que le général se serait mis
au passage trois millions de francs dans
la poche
pire après la libération de sa firme
chimique qui lui demandait tout de même
quelques comptes
il aurait menacé de lui tirer une balle
dans la tête le général s'est fait
porter pâle et couches sous bonne
surveillance dans cet hôpital militaire
il crie au complot d'autant que ces
derniers jours deux autres généraux de
gendarmerie ont été placés sous enquête
le général maurice chef duros une unité
anti mafia pour pour témoignages et même
le chef suprême des carabiniers le
général sir à khouza pour une sombre
affaire liée à l'extrême droite
et du coup c'est tout ce corps de cent
mille hommes
fondée en 1814 sur le modèle de la
gendarmerie française qui se trouve
déstabilisé le président tchèque vaclav
havel opéré hier soir d'urgence en
autriche d'une perforation des
d'intestin va mieux même si ses médecins
reste réservé sur les suites à donner à
cette opération
la secrétaire d'état au tourisme
michelle demessine a provoqué un joli
tollé en angleterre en déclarant que les
touristes anglais devait venir nombreux
au mois de juin en france au moment de
la coupe du monde de football alors que
les autorités de londres dans le même
temps font tout pour empêcher ceux qui
n'ont pas de billets pour assister au
match de traverser la manche afin
d'éviter le débarquement de leur trop
fameux hooligans philippe visseyrias
pascal quint
hier encore inconnue des britanniques
aujourd'hui à la une de la presse
anglaise le passage de michèle demessine
à londres a déclenché une polémique
certains journaux l'accusant même ce
matin d'avoir lancé une invitation à la
bagarre pourquoi un tel scandale
tout est parti d'une simple conférence
de presse hier à londres michelle
demessine est venu vanter le sens de
l'accueil à la française mais elle est
allée plus loin en invitant le plus de
monde possible à venir en france pendant
la coupe du monde
une déclaration que les autorités
anglaises ont eu du mal à comprendre
depuis des semaines le gouvernement
britannique a lancé cette campagne
publicitaire à l'attention de ses
supporters son message est clair pour
que tout se passe bien si vous n'avez
pas de billet pour la coupe du monde
n'allez pas en france en juin prochain
il ya un sentiment en angleterre que les
français le prennent par le sérieux la
menace que posent certains groupes de
hooligans qui sont très très très très
organisés qui sont soit disant ils ont
déjà des projets de
de troubles de france sept étaient donc
les anglais sont vraiment très très
paranoïaque insu aujourd'hui de retour à
paris michèle demessine a voulu calmer
le jeu mon intention n'était pas de
m'adresser aux spectateurs ou mon
attention était de m'adresser aux 12
millions de touristes que nous recevons
chaque année 12 millions de touristes
britanniques que la france ne veut pas
perdre car accueillir la coupe du monde
cela n'a pas que des avantages en 1990
l'italie pays organisateur avait vu sa
fréquentation touristique chuté de 30%
pendant l'épreuve
la présence de milliers de supporters
avaient fait fuir les amoureux des
vieilles pierres
nous évoquions ici même hier soir
largement le rapport du conseil
économique et social sur les
conséquences du bruit et les moyens de
lutter contre
parmi ceux ci un nous avait échappé
momentanément celui des instruments de
musique silencieux pour les voisins
en tout cas laurent le job lubin
faire de la musique sans faire de bruit
n'est pas précisément le fantasme absolu
du musicien mais c'est d'actualité
les français souffrent des nuisances
sonores alors les instruments s'adapte
ce violon vient de sortir grâce au
numérique
il permet de jouer en silence avec un
casque on appelle ça les salons
d'instruments les instruments silencieux
seuls les saxophones et clarinettes et
les flûtes ne peuvent se plier au
système mais moyennant 6 mille francs de
surcoût on peut désormais faire taire un
piano acoustique
enfin comment fonctionne ce piano pascal
annoncé sa part dépasse nos
traditionnels qu'on appelle piano silent
ont plus car il est doté d'un système
qui permet de en fait de pouvoir jouer
au casque mais la différence à capter
votre avis sur les classiques et qu'ils
étaient coupées un système silent avec
une part qui se place entre marteau et
les cordes
ce qui permet au piano devenir
complètement silencieux vous avez des
capteurs optiques qui sont fixés sous
les touches qui permettent de regarder
ce que vous jouez exactement pour
retransmettre un son numérique qui
devrait être transmis au volant un
casque dans ce magasin parisien un piano
vendus sur trois est silencieux on
trouve aussi les batteries des
trompettes du même type
et tout cela nous dit on n'est pas
simplement destinée à préserver la santé
psychique des voisins ça a un avantage
c'est que ça facilite la concentration
lorsque vous apprenez un instrument est
rousse vous sentez que vous gêner ce
n'est pas agréable et cd consentent à
l'avenir les jeunes musiciens concentrer
pour ont donc étudié la musique sans
nous faire subir ça
dommage non
il y à 86 ans très exactement dans la
nuit du 15 avril 1912 le titanic sombré
après avoir percuté un iceberg lors de
son voyage inaugural après le succès
phénoménal du film tout ce qui a trait à
l'histoire de ce naufrage prend une
nouvelle ampleur ainsi on s'est aperçu
que chaque année un petit village des
côtes célébrer la mémoire du capitaine
en second du paquebot dont l'attitude au
moment du drame a été quelque peu
dénaturé dans le scénario du film i'm
gay au fin fond de l'ecosse adal petit
ce fut aujourd'hui comme un jour de
parole il a suffi d'une poignée d'hommes
dans les rues du village
mais pas n'importe lesquels un député et
un producteur de cinéma pour célébrer la
mémoire d'un enfant du village
le héros de dalles petit william murdoch
c'était le commandant en second du
titanic mort en 1912 lors du naufrage
après avoir sauvé des vies c'était en
tout cas ce que tout le monde croyait
ici jusqu'au jour où le film terni cette
image
dans la fiction l'homme n'a plus rien
d'un héros
il tire sur un passager qui tentent
d'embarquer dans un canot de sauvetage
avant de se suicider en écosse ce fut
une blessure
mon électorat a eu le sentiment que le
portrait demeure doj étaient très
éloignés d'arrêt car depuis toutes ces
années
les habitants ont toujours considéré que
murdoch était un héros quelqu'un qui a
donné sa vie entre douch a n'est pas que
le portrait de lui dans le film
s'éloigne vraiment ce député prix tout
simplement sa plume pour exiger la
réhabilitation de l'officier murdoch une
bataille pour l'honneur perdu alors la
production du film fit tout simplement
amende honorable en ce jour le directeur
de la fox en personne aux frites un joli
chèque de 50 mille francs au lycée que
fréquentait jadis william murdoch
l'histoire du titanic fait aujourd'hui
le tour du monde en attisant les
patients jeu le polémique car si
réaliste soit elle la fiction n'est sans
doute pas si fidèle à la réalité
en tout cas elle ne saurait être un
document historique
le cinéma justement le grand maître
américain du film fantastique et
dépôts-vente john carpenter a réalisé
pour la première fois un film sur les
vampires on peut résumer ainsi le
scénario
les chasseurs de primes traque les
suceurs de sang en portage stéphane
haumant jean-paul chausset
les morts-vivants un mythe increvable
après tant d'autres réalisateurs john
carpenter a le démon minuit mais au delà
des clichés
il ajoute sa griffe et son mordant a
déjà vu un vampire
non bon alors primo sont rien de
romantique doigts sont pas des ventes de
pau fuzati perchicot ski ça joue super
2000 qui séduisent leur monde avec un
accent qui vient quand c'est trop j'ai
ça n'a rien à voir avec des vampires
signer les croise la marche blanche
les chasseurs de vampires sont filmés
comme des mercenaires carpenter a
toujours aimé les westerns
si vous avez une dent contre les films
de dracula
si vous avez peur des images chocs fait
une croix sur ce film ambiance 100%
sanglante les suceurs de sang m la nuit
la violence et les femmes
c'est une tradition au bout de six ans
en paquet fonctionne toujours aussi bien
quand le mythe est né en angleterre a
cité la victorieuse récurent iter les
vampires présenter la séduction la
passion ils ont toujours été des
créatures très sexy son sixième film
après halloween fog new york 1997
carpenter est toujours possédé par son
thème favori
la peur nous avons tous eu peur de
l'inconnu date de la souffrance et la
mort
c'est une émotion partagée par les
salles du monde entier
la peur grandit avec on meurt avec ça
tombe bien on meurt beaucoup d'un
vampire
mais dans ce conte crépusculaire il
n'est pas sûr que ce soit les mortels
qui l'emportent chez carpenter le mal a
la vie dure
tu sors je te traqueraient le printemps
de bourges ouvre ses portes ce soir
une manifestation qui vous savez permet
souvent la découverte des stars de la
chanson de demain parmi les candidats à
la gloire cette année une bande de
copains français maghrébins algériens
marocains douze musiciens qui ont choisi
avec beaucoup d'humour il faut le dire
de s'appeler l' orchestre national de
barbès caroline audrin 10 des dames
seniors castrés nationale c'est chic
mais ça plaît orchestre national de
barbès
c'est encore plus chic un pied de nez à
tous ceux qui considèrerait comme mineur
la musique du maghreb
quelques heures
ce sont les enfants de barbès ils vivent
en france depuis une dizaine d'années
leur point d'ancrage c'est ici dans ce
petit bout d'afrique au pied du sacré
coeur à paris
tout le monde se connaît plus ou moins
c'est le premier endroit où débarquent
que les immigrés en quête d'un peu de
chaleur
c'est là où quand on a la nostalgie
on parle bien habermas et on oublie tout
et puis t'as pas besoin de comment dire
de prendre un billet d'avion pour aller
voir comment il au monde vient à barbès
tu auras un aperçu concret de ce que
c'est le monde
ils sont nés chacun avec une musique
celle de marrakech différente de celle
de sidi bel abbès ils ont grandi au son
du rock du reggae du jazz riche de toute
cette culture musicale ils ont fondé
leur groupe il ya trois ans après des
mois de répétitions pas mal de concerts
ils ont trouvé leur identité
le cas beaucoup d'improvisation dans nos
concerts donc c'est une découverte
progressive de chacun envers les
musiques de l'autre et on apprend à se
connaître nous mêmes
humainement et aussi de la musique en
moi
le buzz est dit
l'histoire de ces huit arabe et de ses
quatre français est belle ils sont
restés fidèles à la musique du maghreb
ils l'ont même fait apprécier au jour
une sorte de conte musical où le racisme
n'aurait pas sa place
on nous quitter le rappel des principaux
titres de l'actualité de ce mercredi
d'abord cette prise record pour les
douaniers français 358 cachets d'ecstasy
de drogue qui séduit de plus en plus
consommateurs qui ne se met une table de
ses effets secondaires corse deux mois
et demi après l'assassinât du préfet
claude erignac c'est le grand
chambardement de lune avec aujourd'hui
le remplacement d'un préfet et du patron
de la police judiciaire
une ministre agriculture louis le pensec
vient d'annoncer qu'il recevrait
vendredi matin les représentants des
producteurs bretons de choux fleurs des
légumes qui viennent d'accepter ce
rendez vous avec leurs mythes voilà dans
un instant à la météo isabelle martinet
il ne me reste plus qu'à vous souhaiter
une excellente soirée sur notre chaîne
bonsoir alba
autre
je
e